Hi, I'm Max and I work as an Assistant Psychologist in the Learning Disability Service in West Yorkshire. Like most people working in psychology, I'm slowly but surely working myself up to that seemingly impossible goal of getting onto the clinical doctorate. With that end goal in mind, I thought I'd have a look at what's out there and see what books might be helpful for us. I came across Marianne's book, The Clinical Psychologist Collective, and decided that this would be a great buy for me to help me on my journey. I found Marianne's book really informative, most insightful. I especially liked how the stories reassured me that you don't need to be academically perfect to become a psychologist and that
嗨，我是马克斯，我是西约克郡学习障碍服务部门的一名助理心理学家。就像大多数从事心理学工作的人一样，我正在稳步而坚定地朝着那个看似不可能的目标努力，那就是考取临床心理学博士学位。怀着这个终极目标，我想了解一下目前的现状，看看有哪些书对我们会有所帮助。我偶然读到了玛丽安的书《临床心理学家集锦》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective），并认为这是一本对我很有帮助的好书，能助力我的求职之路。我发现玛丽安的书信息量极大，且极具启发性。我尤其喜欢书中的故事，它们让我确信：成为一名心理学家并不需要你在学术上十全十美，只要
as long as you have good interpersonal skills such as compassion and empathy you will get there. I would highly recommend this book to all aspiring psychologists and also those who want to know a bit more about the world of clinical psychology and maybe want to work in that field one day. Have you ever wondered if the way you've always felt, overwhelmed, socially drained, or like you're speaking a different language to everyone else, could perhaps be an indication that you are autistic?
你具备良好的社交技能，比如同情心和共情能力，你就一定能成功。我强烈向所有有志成为心理学家的人推荐这本书，同时也推荐给那些想对临床心理学世界有更多了解，并且也许有一天想在该领域工作的人。你是否曾好奇过，你一直以来感受到的那种不知所措、社交电量耗尽，或者感觉自己和周围其他人说着完全不同的语言，这或许表明你是一个自闭症患者？
For so many adults, growing awareness and insight and increasing awareness into neurodiversity means that diagnosis happens much later in life. In this episode, Dr. Katie and I walk you through the signs, the process, and what the journey to an adult autism diagnosis can really look like. Hope you find it super useful. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast.
对许多成年人来说，对神经多样性的认识和洞察不断提高，意味着确诊往往发生在生命的较晚阶段。在本期节目中，我和凯蒂博士将为您详细讲解成年自闭症的确诊迹象、流程，以及成年自闭症诊断之旅的真实面貌。希望您会觉得超级有用。嗨，欢迎收听《有志心理学家播客》。
I'm Dr. Marianne, a qualified clinical psychologist. Thank you also for today for sticking with my voice, which is not always as present as it usually is. Virtual throat lozenges in the comments are so gratefully received. With no further ado, let's dive in and catch up on my chat with Dr Katie Adolphus, where we're looking at adult autism assessment and diagnosis. I will catch you on the other side. Hi Katie, Dr Katie Adolphus. Welcome to the podcast. Thank you very much. Thanks for having me. Well, thank you for being here. You are a clinical psychologist and you specialize in working with people of all ages who might fit within a diagnostic criteria for autism and or for ADHD. Today we are thinking about autism. Thank you for pitching this episode to me. Could you tell us a little bit in case someone has no idea what is autism and
我是玛丽安博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。也感谢大家今天包容我这把状态不如往常的声音。评论区里的虚拟润喉糖我真是感激不尽。废话不多说，让我们直接切入正题，回顾我与凯蒂·阿道夫斯（Katie Adolphus）博士的交流，我们将探讨成人自闭症的评估与诊断。我们在另一端见。嗨，凯蒂，凯蒂·阿道夫斯博士。欢迎来到本播客。非常感谢。谢谢邀请我。好的，谢谢你来到这里。你是一位临床心理学家，专门从事各个年龄段人群的工作，这些人群可能符合自闭症和/或注意力缺陷多动障碍（ADHD）的诊断标准。今天我们来探讨自闭症。谢谢你向我推荐这一期节目。能不能给我们简单讲讲，如果有人完全不知道什么是自闭症，
how might people observe that in themselves or others? Very happy to. So autism is considered to be a neurological difference, so it's about how your brain has developed and it impacts or influences how people see the world from a sensory point of view, from a social and relationship point of view, and from in terms of kind of their communication style and preferences. So it's a difference rather than a deficit or a disorder. And so it has equal value, but those are the domains, some of the domains in which you might notice differences. Thank you and adult autism diagnosis are very much becoming more spoken about more recently.
人们可能会在自己或他人身上观察到哪些表现？我很乐意。自闭症被认为是一种神经差异，也就是说，这是关于你的大脑是如何发育的，它会从感官角度、社交与人际关系角度，以及沟通风格与偏好等方面，影响或左右人们看待世界的方式。因此，它是一种差异，而不是一种缺陷或障碍。它具有同等的价值，但这些领域，正是你可能会注意到差异的某些领域。谢谢你，并且近年来成人自闭症诊断也越来越受到人们的讨论。
Can I ask what triggers or what things might happen in someone's adult life that might make them begin to question whether they might be autistic Katie? to question whether they might be autistic, Katie? Of course. So one of the really common ones is that a child of theirs has been identified as autistic or neurodivergent, which is the kind of umbrella term for lots of different neurodevelopmental differences, and that that has made them kind of look back and reflect on their own childhood, their own experiences and how they are understanding the world, that brings them to a point of wanting clarification for themselves. But it might also be somebody who's had some
请问凯蒂，究竟是什么诱因或事情发生在某人的成年生活中，会让他们开始怀疑自己可能是自闭症患者呢？当然。其中一个非常常见的诱因是，他们的孩子被确诊为自闭症或神经发散者——这是对许多不同神经发育差异的一种统称。这使得他们开始回溯并反思自己的童年、自己的经历以及他们是如何理解世界的，从而让他们产生了为自己寻求明确答案的想法。但这也可能是某人在
struggles in the workplace and struggles to reach their potential or those kind of relationship hiccups that are having an impact on their wellbeing. Lots of adults talk about having their intentions misunderstood so that they come out a situation giving, making really clear and direct communication and that's interpreted as rude or brusque or and which is absolutely not that person's intent and similarly obviously it can work the other way where they're struggling to to read somebody else's intent in the way that that other person is intending so those kind of challenges and within kind of the relationships that they experience in the world can often bring someone to wonder about whether they're autistic. Yeah, and just as you were talking, it was making me think about my current context, which I explained before we started to speak.
职场中经历了一些挣扎，难以发挥自己的潜力，或者是那些正在对其福祉产生影响的人际关系摩擦。许多成年人谈到自己的意图被误解，他们走出某个情境时，表达和沟通非常清晰直接，但这却被解读为粗鲁或生硬，而这绝对不是当事人的本意。同样地，反过来也很常见，即他们很难读懂别人的意图，无法理解对方原本想要表达的方式。因此，他们在现实世界中经历的人际关系中遇到的这些挑战，往往会让某人开始怀疑自己是否是自闭症患者。是的，就在你刚才说话的时候，让我想到了我目前的处境，我在开播前也解释过了。
I've hurt my neck and so I'm just fresh back from physio. And I'm kind of imagining whether someone is kind of realizing there's resistance in the way they are socially, the way they're engaging with the world. And actually sometimes even the process of assessment and diagnosis can free that up so that they understand themselves better, or so that they can engage more fully and I guess optimally thrive. Does that sound about right, Katie? Absolutely. And it is about one of my passion for the area is because I'm interested in people's stories
我的脖子受伤了，所以刚从物理治疗那里回来。我在想，是否有人意识到他们在社交方式、与世界互动的方式上存在某种阻力。事实上，有时评估和诊断的过程甚至可以打破这种阻力，让他们更好地了解自己，或者让他们能够更充分地参与其中，我想可以说是达到最佳的繁荣状态。凯蒂，这听起来对吗？完全正确。这也是我对这个领域充满热情的原因之一，因为我对人们的故事很感兴趣，
and the stories that we tell ourselves about ourselves. And if you're autistic, but haven't known that framework to understand yourself, you will have told yourself many stories about how you're doing and other people will have contributed to that as well. And so to having a story that actually what you're describing, there's a community of people who experience the world in similar ways. And there is a way of understanding it so that it is not that you're wrong, it's not that you're broken, it's not that you're mad or crazy or whatever else you might have wondered about for yourself,
以及我们对自己讲述的故事。如果你是自闭症患者，但一直不知道这个框架来理解自己，你就会对自己如何度过生活讲述过很多故事，别人也会对此推波助澜。因此，拥有一个能够解释你所描述的情况的故事——即有一群人和你以相似的方式体验这个世界——并且有一种方式来理解它：这意味着你并没有错，你没有坏掉，你不是疯了，或者任何你可能对自己的其他种种猜测，
but it is that there is a difference and therefore you can advocate for what you need to thrive and develop and build a life around those things that bring you joy, bring you replenishment and build strategies around those bits of life that challenge. Yeah, absolutely. And are there different ways that people of different genders may kind of exhibit signs of perhaps being autistic or things that they're struggling with or maybe even finding easier? What are the gender profiles, Katie? That's a really interesting question because historically what we understood to be autism is what we now understand to be a typically male way of experiencing autism or an external way, a way that's observable to others.
而是说这只是一种差异，因此你可以为自己所需的东西发声，去蓬勃发展、去成长，并围绕那些能给你带来快乐、带来滋养的事物构建生活，同时围绕生活中那些具有挑战性的部分建立应对策略。是的，完全正确。不同性别的人在表现出自闭症迹象、他们可能挣扎的事情，或者甚至觉得更容易的事情上，是否存在不同的表现方式？凯蒂，性别特征是怎样的？这是一个非常有趣的问题，因为从历史上看，我们所理解的自闭症，现在被我们理解为通常男性的自闭症体验方式，或者说是一种外在的、可被他人观察到的方式。
And so it used to be that many more boys and men were thought to be autistic than girls and women. Nowadays, there's a real sense of an understanding of, there's an internal experience of being autistic as well, that is less observable to the observer, but it's very much experienced and can be very, very impactful and very important to understand. So this started being described as the kind of girls version, girls and women's and female version of autism. And now it's better, I think, described as the internal experience of autism, which means that oftentimes girls, women, non-binary and some male people experience the internal version of autism. And so when you're, when we're helping people discover that, you know, we're really being mindful about what's your internal experience of the world.
因此，过去人们认为自闭症男孩和男性的数量远远多于女孩和女性。如今，人们真正开始理解自闭症也存在一种内在体验，这种体验对旁观者来说不太容易观察到，但它是真实存在的体验，可能会产生非常非常大的影响，并且非常重要，值得去理解。因此，这开始被描述为所谓的女孩版、女孩和女性版以及女性版的自闭症。现在，我认为用“自闭症的内在体验”来描述它会更贴切，这意味着通常情况下，女孩、女性、非二元性别者以及一些男性也会体验到内在版本的自闭症。因此，当我们帮助人们发现这一点时，你知道的，我们真的在深思熟虑地关注：你对世界的内在体验是什么？
You know, you might be doing X, Y and Z that neurotypical people might be doing as well, but what's your experience of doing that? What's the cost of doing that to you, your wellbeing and your energy levels? Yeah, what it costs you to engage in your normal life or to be able to go out there and earn money and kind of do all the things. Is that masking or is that something beyond masking? I think it can be described as masking and masking is when you work and it can be conscious or unconscious but when you are kind of going against your internal authentic way of being to be safe in the world, to present as somebody without differences and who fits the majority way of being the majority population.
你知道的，你可能正在做X、Y、Z的事情，神经典型（neurotypical）的人可能也在做这些事，但你做这件事的体验是什么？你为此付出了什么代价？对你的福祉和精力水平有什么影响？是的，为了融入正常生活，或者为了能够外出赚钱并完成所有事情，你付出了什么代价。这究竟是掩饰（masking），还是超越了掩饰的东西？我认为这可以被描述为掩饰。掩饰是指当你努力工作时——这可以是清醒的意识，也可以是无意识的——你违背了自己内在真实的生存方式，以便在这个世界上保持安全，呈现出一个没有差异、能够融入绝大多数普通人群的形象。
And as I said, it can be conscious because I'm not presenting all of myself to you in this podcast. There's parts of me that I'm squishing down and masking and that's a conscious choice and okay. But it can also be unconscious where you've just learned through life's experiences that that bit of you makes you vulnerable. So it's not safe to be that way. Yeah, like socially conditioned, that's undesirable, that's not okay, don't do that. Yeah, don't flap in this way, but it might be okay if you flick your hair. So some of the ways to cope with life might involve what people call stimming which might include flapping any other kind of stimming activities that people
正如我所说，这可以是有意识的，因为我在这个播客中并没有向你展现全部的自己。我身体里有一些部分被我压抑和掩饰了，这是一个有意识的选择，也没问题。但它也可以是无意识的，也就是你通过生活经验了解到，你的那部分特质会让你变得脆弱。因此，展现出那一面并不安全。是的，就像社会条件反射一样，认为那样是不好的、是不被允许的、不要那样做。是的，不要用这种方式拍打双手，但如果你弹一下头发可能还可以。因此，应对生活的一些方法可能会涉及到人们所说的自我刺激行为（stimming），这可能包括拍手或任何其他人们可能会在别人或自己身上看到的
might see in others or in themselves. So sometimes that it might be physical movements, clicking or saying different words. If you think about it, actually, laughing is a stim because a stim is a repetitive movement that happens to help regulate emotion. So laughing is a funny thing we do with our breathing and our voice box when we're feeling a big emotion, whether that's hilarity or embarrassment or whatever. When the emotion gets that big, we do a thing. That's what stims are in lots of ways. There's lots of different types, fiddling with hair, fiddling with your clothes, pacing up and down when you're stressed. There's all sorts of things that, and they stand out from typical, more or less, in different ways. Yeah, so obviously everybody, you know, either with an autism presentation or not, will self-stimulate at times,
自我刺激活动。所以有时它可能是身体动作、发出咔哒声或说不同的词。如果你仔细想想，实际上，大笑也是一种自我刺激，因为自我刺激是一种重复性的动作，有助于调节情绪。因此，当我们感受到强烈的情绪时——无论是狂喜、尴尬还是其他什么——大笑是我们用呼吸和声带做出的一种有趣的事情。当情绪变得如此强烈时，我们就会做出某种反应。这就是自我刺激在很多方面的体现。它有很多不同的类型，比如玩弄头发、摆弄衣服、压力大时来回踱步。有各种各样的东西，它们在不同程度上与典型行为有所区别。是的，所以显然每个人——无论是否表现出自闭症特征——有时都会进行自我刺激，
but actually there's certain key stims and if used repetitively and perhaps not always in conjunction with, I don't know is this the wrong term, but more kind of socially accepted ways of stimulating ourselves like or regulating ourselves like like a soothing rhythm breath for example, that's what we tend to advocate to people but actually if spinning around or flapping you know is doing the same thing but you certainly get a few more stern looks if you're doing that. Yes, yeah, because I don't think people probably think of laughing and those other things that we've described as stims in that way, but I think autistic people can use stims to help regulate perhaps more.
但实际上，某些关键的自我刺激行为如果被重复使用，并且可能并不总是与——我不知道这词用得对不对，但与那些更被社会接受的自我刺激方式结合使用，比如，或者说像自我调节，比如像舒缓的有节奏的呼吸，例如，这才是我们倾向于向人们倡导的。但实际上，如果转圈或拍手在做同样的事情，如果你这样做，你肯定会得到更多严厉的目光。是的，是的，因为我认为人们可能不会把大笑和我们刚才描述的其他事情看作是那种意义上的自我刺激，但我认为自闭症患者可能会更多地利用自我刺激来帮助调节情绪。
I don't know that there's research to check that but that's my experience than neurotypical people and maybe in place of putting words to their internal kind of emotional experience. Yeah I've never thought about laughing as being a I know right. A stim, yeah it's really interesting. Okay so people that laugh a lot that might be more of a stimulatory behaviour. I think I was mentioning that in the context of saying actually stimming is an experience that we all share, whether we're neurotypical or neurodivergent. So that's one way in which there's a shared experience, but that isn't to say I think autistic people use stims more. I see. So there's no correlation between laughing and autism.
我不知道有没有研究来证实这一点，但这是我的经验，他们比神经典型的人用得更多，也许这可以替代用语言来表达他们内在的某种情绪体验。是的，我从来没想过大笑是一种——我懂的，对吧。一种自我刺激，是的，这真的很有趣。好吧，所以那些经常大笑的人，那可能更像是一种自我刺激行为。我想我当时提到这一点是在这样一种语境下：实际上，自我刺激是我们所有人——无论我们是神经典型还是神经发散——共同的一种体验。所以这是存在共同体验的一个方面，但这并不是说我认为自闭症患者会更多地使用自我刺激。原来如此。所以大笑和自闭症之间没有相关性。
It's an example of self-stimming. It's just a way in which experience is similar. I'm with you. Thank you for clarifying that. So, you know, I guess if people have got to this stage of the podcast episode, they'll be thinking, yep, tics a box, tics a box, tics a box. What are the processes involved with getting an autism assessment for an adult? So different NHS trusts do it in different ways, but your GP will be your first port of call to go through the NHS. There's also the system of going through right to choose providers, that's potentially possible.
这只是自我刺激的一个例子。这只是一种体验相似的方式。我明白了。谢谢你澄清这一点。所以，你知道的，我想如果人们听到了播客节目的这个阶段，他们会想：是的，勾选，勾选，勾选。那么，为成年人进行自闭症评估涉及哪些流程呢？不同的NHS（英国国民保健制度）信托机构（Trusts）做法不同，但通过NHS的话，你的全科医生（GP）将是你的第一站。还有一种通过“选择权”（Right to Choose）医疗提供者进行检查的系统，这也有可能。
And then there's the independent sector as well. So I can talk to my own experience of offering adult assessments in the independent sector. That's a system whereby contracts have been set up with different providers to provide a service for NHS clients that remains free at the point of need. So you can go to your GP and ask for consideration of being put on the Right to Choose pathway for an assessment. And there are criteria for whether you can join those pathways and those waiting lists. I don't have details about that because that's not my service doesn't do Right to Choose assessments, but that's a possibility for people within
此外，还有私立医疗行业。所以我可以谈谈我在私立行业提供成人评估的经验。这是一个与不同医疗提供者建立合同的系统，为NHS客户提供服务，并且在需要时保持免费。因此，你可以去看全科医生，要求考虑进入“选择权”通道进行评估。并且对于你是否可以加入这些通道和等待名单，是有相应标准的。我没有这方面的详细信息，因为我的服务部门不做“选择权”评估，但这对于人们来说是一种可能性。
the independent sector. So for us, people make an inquiry and can book an appointment to get an initial, it's like a screening appointment that talks through what brings them to wonder about an assessment and it's really to make sure that an assessment makes sense and isn't a use of resources that isn't meaningful. And then the assessment itself is like a deep dive into someone's experiences in childhood right through up to adulthood, their experience of learning, friendships, relationships of the sensory world, of what's it like, you know, flexibility and plan versus the need for predictability. And we cover that ground in a number of different appointments and doing a number of different tasks
在私立行业。对我们而言，人们进行咨询并可以预约进行初步评估，这就像是一次筛查预约，讨论是什么促使他们想要进行评估，这其实是为了确保评估是有意义的，而不是对资源的无意义消耗。然后评估本身就像是对一个人从童年到成年经历的深入探究，包括他们在学习、友谊、人际关系、感官世界方面的经历，比如体验是怎样的，灵活性和计划性与对可预测性的需求之间的对比。我们在多次不同的预约中涵盖这些内容，并执行许多不同的任务，
just to explore how someone approaches the world. And we ask whether they've got people in their family or network who would they would be comfortable to contribute so we might ask a parent to give us some information about what they remember of their child in their childhood or a partner perhaps that could contribute something and then we pull all of that information together to reach a decision about the possibility of them being autistic. Great so there's not kind of the practical elements as such like you might see in children with with an ADOS assessment for example it's much more kind of conversational and
只是为了探索一个人是如何接触世界的。我们会询问他们是否在家庭或社交网络中有愿意且乐意配合的人，因此我们可能会请父母向我们提供一些信息，让他们回忆孩子童年时的情景，或者请伴侣提供一些信息，然后我们将所有这些信息汇集在一起，就他们是否可能是自闭症患者做出决定。太好了，所以这里没有那种实操性质的要素——就像你在儿童身上可能会看到的ADOS（自闭症诊断观察量表）评估那样，它更多的是基于对话和
relational. It is it is more conversational in with adults and some services including ours we do still do the AD ADOS, but the ADOS that we do for adults is still fairly conversational. There's a few tasks, but it's not as task heavy as the ADOS that we might do for children. I was in a school meeting recently and there was a copy of that book, is it called Tuesday? It's got frogs in it. it. I think that was in the ADOS at one stage. And there's no words in it. And I said to the teacher, I said, did you know actually this is commonly used as kind of a screen for trying to work out what
关系的。确实如此，对于成年人来说，它更多是基于对话的。一些服务机构（包括我们机构）确实仍在进行ADOS测试，但我们针对成人进行的ADOS测试仍然相当偏向对话性质。会有一些任务，但它不像我们可能对儿童进行的ADOS那样任务繁重。我最近参加了一个学校会议，里面有一本那本书，是叫《星期二》（Tuesday）吗？里面有青蛙的那本。我想那本书曾经在ADOS测试中出现过。而且里面没有字。我对老师说，我说，你知道吗？实际上这通常被用作一种筛查工具，用来弄清楚
might be going on and what people's understanding of that is and it's used as part of autism assessments. You're just like, no, I had no idea. We just use it as a picture book. And I was like, well, actually, you can use it in that way to kind of think about pre-screening. Is there anything that someone could do if they're preparing for going in for an initial assessment to prepare for that kind of optimally. So maybe we used to do developmental assessment reports in clinic. Could they have those conversations with their parents, with people who knew them when they were a child and think about all of that? What are top questions or top ways of preparing do you think? I think what we often mention to adults is to just spend some time ahead of the appointments,
可能会发生什么以及人们对此的理解是什么，它被用作自闭症评估的一部分。你就会觉得，不，我完全不知道。我们只是把它当作一本图画书来用。我说，嗯，实际上，你可以用这种方式来做初步筛查。如果有人在准备去进行初次评估时，为了以最佳状态做好准备，有没有什么事情是他们可以做的呢？比如，我们以前在诊所做过发展评估报告。他们可以和父母、和那些在他们小时候就认识他们的人进行这些对话，并思考所有这些事情吗？你认为有哪些顶级问题或最佳准备方式？我想我们经常向成年人提到的一点是，在预约前花点时间，
reminiscing and kind of maybe that's talking with parents as you say or siblings about and thinking about okay where was I when I started primary where did I live what school did I go to so just trying to really put yourself in those times, because then accessing memories of those times will be easier. So it might be looking through school reports or photos from school days, anything that can just bring those early years to the kind of more accessible bit of your memory, years to the kind of more accessible bit of your memory really. So that can be really helpful so that you know they've done some digging around in their life experience before they get to us. Yeah absolutely and if someone is kind of heavily defended or so used to masking can it be hard to kind of really work out whether
回忆过往，正如你所说，也许可以和父母或兄弟姐妹谈谈，思考一下：我上小学时我在哪里？我住在哪里？我上的是哪所学校？试着真正让自己回到那个时代，因为这样一来，调取那些时期的记忆就会变得更容易。所以这可能包括翻阅学校报告或上学时的照片，任何能把那些早期岁月带到你的记忆中更容易获取的部分的事情。实际上，这真的很有帮助，这样当他们来到我们这里之前，就已经在自己的人生经历中做了一些挖掘。是的，绝对的。如果一个人被深度防御（heavily defended）或者习惯了掩饰，那么很难真正弄清楚
they do fulfill that diagnostic criteria? Can you always kind of sieve out what needs to come through? I think that's something that actually a lot of people are worried about. The fact that they've gone a lifetime so far without it being identified might either mean that it doesn't exist and they're making it all up and they're over-exaggerating concerns or what have you, or that an assessment process won't uncover it. So we work really hard to get underneath the mask
他们是否真的符合诊断标准吗？你总是能够抽丝剥茧地找出需要呈现的东西吗？我认为这实际上是很多人担心的事情。他们迄今为止一生都没有被确诊，这可能意味着要么根本不存在这个问题，是他们在凭空捏造、过度夸大担忧等等，要么就是评估过程无法将其揭示出来。因此，我们付出了很大的努力来揭开面具，
and actually sometimes that's why the ADOS can be helpful. It's not without its issues, but it can be helpful. Because it's kind of odd. Some of the tasks and things that we do are just slightly odd. So it's unlikely that you've kind of created a script for it or kind of quite prepared for it. So in that kind of way, it can be a helpful way to get underneath the mask. And there are other kind of adult
事实上，这也是为什么ADOS有时会很有用的原因。它并非没有问题，但它确实很有帮助。因为这有点奇怪。我们所做的一些任务和事情有点奇怪。所以你不太可能为此提前写好剧本或者做好了充分准备。从这种角度来看，它可以成为揭开面具的有用途径。还有其他一些基于成年的
based assessment tools that help us do that as well. To get underneath the mask. Yeah, and it's making me think of when I was training in my doctorate in clinical psychology, and they were like, actually, when you are a clinical psychologist, and you're familiar with all these measures it does actually make it a bit harder to test you laterally because you know the answers and you know what's coming. Are there certain professions that are more likely to have an autism diagnosis, to be autistic or kind of to be
评估工具也能帮助我们做到这一点。来揭开面具。是的，这让我想起我在攻读临床心理学博士学位接受培训的时候，当时他们说，实际上，当你成为一名临床心理学家，并且熟悉所有这些测量标准时，要对你进行侧向测试（test laterally）其实会变得更难，因为你知道答案，也知道接下来会发生什么。有没有某些职业更有可能获得自闭症诊断、本身是自闭症患者，或者倾向于
gravitating towards that? I know that always when I was working in CAMHS for example, we found, so I was working in West Midlands, very close to kind of Jaguar engineering bases and it was said that actually this is a kind of almost a hotbed of children and young people with autism presentations, whether they're diagnosed or not, because their moms or their dads or both are actually engineers. And that was thought to be kind of something that naturally lots of people with autism would gravitate towards.
从事这类工作呢？我知道以前我在儿童和青少年心理健康服务（CAMHS）工作时，我们发现——我在西米德兰兹工作，非常靠近捷豹（Jaguar）工程基地——据说这实际上可以说是患有自闭症表现的儿童和青少年的温床，无论他们是否被确诊，因为他们的妈妈或爸爸或双方实际上都是工程师。人们认为这似乎是许多自闭症患者会自然而然倾向于从事的领域。
Does that make sense? It does, it does. And I don't know what the current sense is about that specifically, but I remember historically there being research around you know certain but if we think about it more broadly from certain professions but think about kind of what is the the cognitive style of someone who's autistic and so autistic people are ordinarily fantastic at paying attention to one thing at a time.
这说得通吗？说得通，确实说得通。我不知道目前对此的具体看法是什么，但我记得历史上曾有过相关的研究，关于某些……但如果我们从更广泛的角度来思考某些职业，而是去思考自闭症患者的认知风格是什么样的，那么自闭症患者通常非常擅长一次专注于一件事。
And they can often do that above and beyond the kind of attention span of a neurotypical person. So, and have those really highly specialized, highly specific areas of, of interest and depth of knowledge and understanding. So professions or disciplines that require that suit an autistic way of being in the world. Autistic minds are really good at that kind of all or nothing. Something is either true or false, right or wrong in really clear ways. So professions that might be served by having that perspective and where communication is really clear and explicit. So there'll be some areas of law
而且他们往往能超越神经典型之人的注意力跨度。因此，他们拥有那些高度专业化、高度特定领域的兴趣、深厚的知识和理解。因此，那些需要这种特质的职业或学科，非常适合自闭症患者在世界上的生存方式。自闭症患者的大脑非常擅长那种非黑即白、非此即彼的思维。某些事情在非常清晰的层面上要么是对的，要么是错的，要么是真的，要么是假的。因此，那些能够从这种视角中受益、并且沟通非常清晰明确的职业，就会很适合他们。因此，在某些法律领域中，
where having that real clarity of thought about, well, this means that and the other thing means the other thing can bring a real strength to that field. So it's about fields that benefit from an autistic way of being. And there might be other disciplines or professions or ways of living your adult life that lend themselves to people who don't need as much social interaction to keep their social tank of energy full. So those, I was speaking with one adult I know who's autistic and through school he got, you know, those quizzes that you can take about what profession you should go into and his answer was lighthouse keeper. And I thought, well, that's just glorious because he can, you know, he would have the free, that's not what he became ultimately. But I thought, well, what a glorious way of being, you know, if that suits your, the amount of social isolation versus interaction that works for you.
对“这代表这个，另一件事代表那个”拥有这种清晰的思维，能够为该领域带来真正的优势。所以这是关于那些受益于自闭症生存方式的领域。还会有其他学科、职业或成年生活方式，它们本身更适合那些不需要太多社交互动来保持社交精力库满格的人。比如，我曾和一位我认识的自闭症成年人交谈过，他在学校时做过那种关于你该选择什么职业的测试，他的答案是：灯塔看守人。当时我想，这真是太棒了，因为他可以……（最终他没有从事这个职业）。但我想，如果这种生活方式适合你的社交孤立度与互动量之间的平衡，那将是多么棒的一种生存状态啊。
Perfect. Yeah, we are all so different, aren't we? That would be a terrible job for me. I love speaking with people. I love random conversations with people. I'm the sort of person that will chat to someone in Tesco over the cauliflowers. But we're all so very different. But actually, what we know is that people can reach what's called autistic burnout when they're really struggling with the resources they've got
太完美了。是的，我们都如此不同，对吧？那对我就将是一份糟糕的工作。我喜欢和人说话。我喜欢和人进行随机的聊天。我是那种会在Tesco（乐购）超市的菜花货架旁和别人聊天的人。但我们所有人都非常不同。不过实际上，我们所知道的是，当人们真正为了应付生活所需的一切而苦苦挣扎时，他们可能会达到被称为“自闭症倦怠”（autistic burnout）的状态。
to be able to do all the things that life necessitates. Could you tell us a bit more about autistic burnout? Sure. So it's a term that the autistic community have kind of, I don't know if the a community but the first to kind of use it, but certainly it really resonates with lots of people's experience and it describes that chronic ongoing emotional kind of and cognitive and social exhaustion that being neurodivergent in a neurotypical world can generate. And so if you're in that chronic state of using up more resources than you've got, because the world requires that of you, then you stay in that depletion and kind of you're in energy debt, so to speak, which can have an impact on how well or otherwise you manage a new function in the world. So burnout can look like losing areas of functioning that have previously been okay for you.
你能多给我们讲讲自闭症倦怠吗？当然。这是一个自闭症群体创造的术语，我不知道是不是某个群体首创的，但它确实引起了许多人经历的强烈共鸣，它描述了在神经典型世界中作为神经发散者所产生的这种慢性的、持续的情绪、认知和社交上的精疲力竭。因此，如果你处于这种消耗的资源多于你所拥有的资源的慢性状态中——因为世界对你提出了这样的要求——那么你就会一直处于这种枯竭状态，可以说是处于能量赤字状态，这会对你管理和在世界上运作良好与否产生影响。因此，倦怠可能表现为丧失了以前对你来说还算正常的运作能力。
So you might eat less, be unable to speak for a period, and just need to be in bed by yourself for long stretches because the world is hard and exhausting without it being set up for you. Thank you. Thank you for helping us understand a bit more about that. And when people kind of receive a diagnosis, you know, they might respond in a variety of different ways. It might feel like, ah, finally,, I feel like I know myself and I can kind of get out there and tell people about me and people will understand me better or
所以你可能会吃得更少，一段时间内无法说话，并且需要长时间独自呆在床上，因为这个世界对你来说太艰难、太精疲力竭了，而且它并不是为你量身定制的。谢谢你。谢谢你帮助我们更多地了解这一点。当人们接到诊断结果时，他们可能会有各种各样的反应。这可能会让人觉得：啊，终于，我觉得我了解自己了，我可以走出去向别人介绍自己，别人也会更好地理解我，或者
I will care less about what other people think of me. Yeah, like is it always a good thing? Does it sometimes feel like a negative thing or like the shame or judgment or blame or it's kind of their fault that's going to internalize process there? That's a really, really important question because we shouldn't be doing it if it's not ultimately helpful and meaningful. My experience in talking with people is that, and what I witness often starts with relief, you know, to kind of to have reached the point where you have wondered why the world seems more difficult to navigate for you than it does for others, has suddenly got a framework around it to understand that,
我会更不在乎别人怎么看我。是的，这总是一件好事吗？有时它会感觉像是一件消极的事情吗？或者会有伴随而来的羞耻、评判、指责，或者说这是一种内部转化的过程？这是一个非常非常重要的问题，因为如果最终不能带来帮助和意义，我们就不应该去做这件事。根据我与人们交谈的经验，以及我所看到的，这种经历通常以解脱开始，你知道的，终于走到了这样一个节点：你曾疑惑为什么世界对你而言比对其他人更难驾驭，而现在周围终于有了一个框架来理解这一点，
which brings with it things that might be helpful to make life less difficult to navigate. So it often starts with relief. I think there are also in the journey periods of time where it's like, oh, blind me, but in the journey periods of time where it's like, oh, blind me, but that's lifelong. So that means it's going to always be difficult and that's hard. So I think that's potentially a stage or a position that people kind of go in and out of as well. And I think there can be elements of grief and loss about, gosh, if this was understood about me in earlier years, how different could things have been? And I think what the joy of doing
这带来了一些有助于让生活不那么难以驾驭的东西。所以它通常以解脱开始。我认为在这个旅程中，也会有一段时间让人觉得：哦，天哪，但在这个旅程的某些阶段，你会觉得：哦，天哪，这是终身的。这意味着它将永远都很艰难，而这很难接受。所以我认为这可能也是人们会进进出出的一个阶段或立场。而且我认为其中也会包含对悲伤和失落的体验，比如：天哪，如果早年间人们就能这样理解我，事情会有多么不同呢？我认为做这项工作的美妙之处在于：
this work is a the relief in the beginning and then the kind of coming through the processing of this framework to your life, coming to a point of validation and acceptance and strength and a way of building self-compassion, building self-esteem, which just was so vital to well-being and emotional and mental health, aren't they? Yeah, absolutely. And I think, you know, I think, encourages us to make our own bespoke way of existing in the world in a way that does suit us, suit our own individual needs, our family needs, just our preferences.
开始时的解脱，然后经历对这个生活框架的处理过程，最终达到一种认可、接纳和力量的状态，以及建立自我同情、建立自尊的方式——这些对于福祉以及情绪和心理健康来说是至关重要的，对吧？是的，完全正确。而且我认为，这鼓励我们以一种真正适合我们、适合我们个人需求、家庭需求以及个人偏好的方式，在世界上创造出属于我们自己的独一无二的生存方式。
It's almost like we can paint by numbers now. We can really have our lives, I don't know, vibe with us, not just one size fits all. So employment doesn't suit everybody. But so many of us for so many years have been told, you do this, you go to school, you get your A-levels, you go to uni, you get a job, then you retire. Like, there are your options, that's it. And I think it's really made us think, actually, I don't know. I don't know if I want that. And employment that's in a shared office where you have to manage the noise and the hubbub of everybody around you and the chance that they might pass you and
这几乎就像我们现在可以按数字填色一样。我们可以真正让我们的生活——我不知道——与我们的氛围契合，而不仅仅是“一刀切”。因此，就业并不适合所有人。但多年来，我们当中有那么多的人被告知：你做这个，你上学，你考A-level（高级水平考试），你上大学，你找工作，然后你退休。看，这就是你的选择，就是这样。我认为这确实让我们开始思考：实际上，我不知道。我不知道我是否想要那样。比如在共享办公室里工作，你必须应付周围所有人的噪音和嘈杂声，还要面对他们可能会路过你身边的可能性，
and make some inconsequential social chitchat comment that doesn't suit how you function and then going actually I can do this work, I can be productive and I'm not using up my social battery to do it. I can use my social batteries in ways that replenish me. When I was working in a shared office, people just like to talk, don't they? And I like to talk as well. But if I've got work to do as well, I almost had to get myself in work mode and wear my AirPods and risk being quite rude to people because otherwise I would not get my work done. And then the clients, my patients, don't get what they need. They don't get their reports, they don't get their clinical notes done. And
并说一些无关紧要的社交闲聊，这并不符合你的运作方式。然后你会想：实际上我可以做这份工作，我可以很有成效，而且我不需要耗费我的社交电量来做到这一点。我可以把我的社交电量用在那些能滋养我的地方。以前在共享办公室工作时，大家就是喜欢聊天，对吧？我也喜欢聊天。但如果我还有工作要做，我几乎必须让自己进入工作模式，戴上AirPods，冒着被认为对人相当粗鲁的风险，否则我就无法完成工作。那样的话，我的客户、我的病人们就无法得到他们所需的东西。他们拿不到报告，完不成临床记录，然后
I'm in trouble. So yeah, like, and I'd have to explain to my colleagues, actually, when I've got my AirPods in, as much as I'd love to chat. I can't. That's like, that's closing the door on your individual office, isn't it? Yeah, but if you haven't got one. So that's the sign of it absolutely. Yeah absolutely. So yeah like if people are thinking oh yeah that this could be worth exploring, is there a generic
我就有麻烦了。所以，是的，比如，我不得不向同事们解释：实际上，当我戴着AirPods时，尽管我很想聊天，但我不能。这就像是在你自己的独立办公室里关上了门，对吧？是的，但如果你没有独立办公室呢。所以这绝对是个迹象。是的，完全如此。所以，是的，如果人们在想：哦，是的，这或许值得探索，那么对于一个人可能预期花费的费用，有没有一个大致的
ballpark figure for what someone might be expecting to spend? It might be a range for an adult autism assessment. I think it is a range rather than a precise figure, but I would be expecting around about maybe a bit under, maybe a bit over £2,000 for it, which is a huge, a huge amount of resources. So if I was somebody in that, and you can definitely get it cheaper, I'm talking about services that multidisciplinary and particularly strong, you know, particularly thoughtfully and carefully
价格范围？成人自闭症评估的费用可能是一个范围，而不是一个精确的数字。我认为这是一个范围而不是一个确切的数字，但我预计费用大概在2000英镑左右，可能稍微少一点，也可能稍微多一点。这是一笔巨额的资源消耗。所以如果我是处于那种情况的人——你当然可以找到更便宜的，我指的是多学科且实力特别强、尤其经过深思熟虑和谨慎处理的服务，
because that takes a lot of resources. I think if you're thinking about pursuing that, speak to services that you find, ask them whether they fulfil what's called the NICE guidelines, Ask them whether they fulfill what's called the NICE guidelines because those are the, as you'll know, the NICE guidelines. They describe what is required for any, for an assessment. And it means that if the service you go to fulfill those NICE guidelines, follow those NICE guidelines, the outcome has a better chance of being accepted in statutory services and in services you approach for things like accommodations and provisions on the basis of any diagnosis that's made. Yeah, so like anything, I guess, especially with the rise of kind of how popular talking
因为那需要消耗大量资源。我想如果你在考虑进行评估，可以去向你找到的服务机构咨询，询问他们是否符合所谓的NICE（英国国家卫生与临床优化研究所）指南，询问他们是否符合所谓的NICE指南，因为正如你所知，这些都是NICE指南。它们描述了任何评估所必需的要求。这意味着，如果你去的服务机构符合这些NICE指南、遵循了这些指南，那么其结果就更有可能被法定服务机构以及你在因任何已做出的诊断而寻求诸如便利和保障等服务时所接触的机构所接受。是的，所以就像任何事情一样，我想，特别是随着在媒体上讨论这个话题的热度上升，我们很可能会看到非常便宜的评估诊断流程，但便宜并不总是最好的。
about this is becoming in the media, we're likely to see very cheap assessment diagnosis processes, but cheap is not always best. Not always. And that's the price range that our assessments are in. So of course, I'm going to tell you that that's the price range to imagine. And I think in services that develop to assess for autism, I think it's really important to think in services that develop to assess for autism, I think it's really important to think about what's required to make a sound and thorough and appropriate, valid assessment. What are the extras that can really add depth and completion to someone's to the outcome and someone's understanding
不一定。这就是我们评估的价格区间。所以当然，我会告诉你这是可以想象的价格区间。我认为在那些专门开展自闭症评估的服务机构中，思考一下做出健全、彻底、恰当且有效的评估究竟需要什么，真的非常重要。有哪些额外内容可以真正为个人的评估结果和自我理解增添深度和完整性，但对于诊断的完整性而言并非必需？因此，每个服务机构和每家诊所都会在略微不同的地方划定这条线，我认为它们划定这条线的位置会有所不同。是的，是的。我认为那些拥有专业资质并在该领域有多年经验的临床医生，具备如此多的技能和优势，这真的很棒。所以即使我在CAMHS团队工作时，也有几位顾问临床心理学家，一位从事专业工作很多年的言语和语言治疗师。
of themselves, but aren't needed for diagnostic integrity. And so each service and each practice will put a line in a slightly different place, put that line in a slightly different place, I think. Yeah, yeah. I think there's so much skills and benefit in clinicians who have professional qualifications and have years of experience in that. So even when I was in the CAMHS team, there was a couple of consultant clinical psychologists, a speech and language therapist who had worked in a qualified capacity for many, many years. I think two OTs actually, and then kind of CBT therapists and people that, you know, you've got all of those years of experience combined but also experience of seeing people that are, you know, neurotypical as well,
我想还有两位职业治疗师（OT），然后是一些CBT（认知行为疗法）治疗师和一些人，你知道的，你汇集了所有这些年的经验，同时也有观察神经典型人群以及跨越不同生命周期人群的经验，这样你就能真正感受到这是否是能够支持和帮助那个人的东西。是的，而且我认为当人们没有达到这些级别的专业资质时，他们就没有这种专业注册。我认为他们只是不具备专业诚信，而且我认为他们个人并不具备从事他们自称专家的工作所需的必要技能？是的，绝对的。而且我认为这真的很难，因为它让身处这种境况的从业者和客户都非常脆弱，他们的诊断结果会受到性质的挑战，对于那些经历过整个评估流程的人来说，其结果受到挑战一定是非常令人难以置信的艰难。我想我还要说的是，玛丽安，评估的成本是一个巨大的障碍，所以会有
people across the lifespan, so that you're really getting a sense of whether this is something that's going to support and help that person. Yeah and I think when people don't have those levels of professional qualifications, they don't have that professional registration. I think they just they don't have the integrity and they don't have, I don't think they've got the requisite skills personally to be doing the work that they are saying they are experts in always? Yeah absolutely and I think it's really difficult as well because it leaves both the practitioners who are in that situation and the clients really vulnerable to having their outcomes challenged and that must be incredibly hard for people who have gone through a process to have the outcome challenged. And I guess I would also say, Marianne, that the cost of it is a huge barrier and so there'll
跨越整个人生阶段的人，这样你就能真正了解这是否能够支持并帮助那个人。是的，我认为当人们没有这些级别的专业资质时，他们就没有那样的专业注册。我认为他们只是缺乏正直感，而且他们没有，我个人认为他们不具备进行他们自称始终是专家的工作所必需的技能？是的，绝对如此，我认为这也真的很困难，因为它让身处那种情况的从业者和客户都非常容易受到其结果受到质疑的影响，对于经历过整个过程却发现结果受到质疑的人来说，这一定极其艰难。我想我还要说的是，玛丽安，这样做的成本是一个巨大的障碍，所以
be many for whom that's impossible. I think self-identifying as autistic, if you've done the work, if it fits your way of being, if it just makes sense of the bits that didn't make sense beforehand, I think that it's valid. It's okay to say that you consider yourself to be autistic. I wouldn't challenge that myself. I think the value of having it clarified through an assessment process is that some autistic minds prefer certainty and so need an external person to go, yep, I agree, this is what it is, you haven't fooled anyone, you haven't exaggerated anything, it is what it is. So that can bring kind of internal peace to that identity kind of claim and also access to kind of the legal protections under
对许多人来说，这可能是做不到的。我认为，如果你做了功课，如果它符合你的生存方式，如果它只是让那些以前说不通的地方说得通了，那么自我认同为自闭症患者是成立的。说你认为自己是自闭症患者是可以的。我自己是不会对此提出质疑的。我认为通过评估流程来明确这一点的价值在于，一些自闭症患者的思维更喜欢确定性，因此需要一个外部人员来确认，是的，我同意，这就是事实，你没有愚弄任何人，你也没有夸大任何事情，事实就是如此。因此，这可以为这种身份认同带来某种内心的平静，并获得
the Equality Act because autism is legally classed as a disability. You don't have to agree that it inherently is but it is legally classed as one so you do get protected by some legislation around kind of people providing support and accommodations to make sure that you thrive rather than burn out. So I think there is real positives for having that formal process but identifying it in yourself and noticing it in yourself and describing yourself that way is valid too. Amazing, thank you so much for your time and for helping us understand more about this. Where's the best place for people to learn more about you and your work, Katie?
《平等法》下的法律保护，因为自闭症在法律上被归类为一种残疾。你不一定要赞同它本质上是这样的，但它在法律上确实被归类为残疾，因此你确实受到一些有关人们提供支持和便利的立法的保护，以确保你能够蓬勃发展而不是精疲力竭。因此，我认为走正式流程确实有很大的积极意义，但在你自己身上识别它、注意到它并以这种方式描述你自己也是同样有效的。太棒了，非常感谢你抽出时间帮助我们更多地了解这一点。凯蒂，大家在哪里可以最好地了解你和你的工作？
So my website is theadolphuspractice.co.uk and we have a Facebook page, which is the Adolphus Practice, and we're on Instagram as the.adolphuspractice. So that's where you find us. Amazing. I will make sure that all of those details are on screen for YouTube and in the show notes and the description everywhere else. Thank you so much again for your time and for putting up with my voice, which almost abandoned us at times today as well.
我的网站是 theadolphuspractice.co.uk，我们还有一个 Facebook 我们的主页是 the Adolphus Practice，我们的 Instagram 账号是 the.adolphuspractice。这就是你能找到我们的地方。太棒了。我一定会确保所有这些详细信息都显示在 YouTube 的屏幕上、节目说明以及其他所有地方的描述中。再次非常感谢你抽出时间，并包容我今天有时几乎失声的嗓音。
I think it's just about held on. Thank you so much. No worries. Thanks so much. Thank you. Thank you so much for your time in listening or watching this episode. If you have found it helpful, please do drop me a like, a comment, a follow, a subscribe. Following a show for a creator that you rate really is the kindest thing you can do for free,
我觉得它刚刚坚持住了。非常感谢。不用谢。非常感谢。非常感谢您抽出时间收听或观看本期节目。如果您觉得有帮助，请给我点赞、评论、关注、订阅。关注您认可的创作者的节目，真的是您可以免费做的最友好的事情，
and I would be so grateful if you could do that for me, please. You might well be engaging with this episode because you are working in the mental health space. If you yourself have an autism diagnosis, you may wonder whether that would make you a good enough mental health professional. And this is where I think the book,
如果您能为我做到这一点，我将不胜感激。您可能正在参与本期节目，因为您在心理健康领域工作。如果您自己被诊断出患有自闭症，您可能会想，这是否会使您成为一名足够优秀的心理健康专业人员。这就是我认为这本书，
An Autistic Anthology, Neuro-Narratives of Mental Health Professionals is really worth checking out. It is a collab, so to speak, between Nikita Sheppardson, Dr. Vicky Jervis and myself and it is real-life look through the lens or for people who self identify as being autistic and the way that they've seen the world, the way that it shaped their experiences and how they've gone on to successfully work in the mental health space. We have psychologists in there, we have psychiatrists in there, there's all sorts of people at different stages of their career and it is a fascinating
《自闭症文集：心理健康专业人员的神经叙事》非常值得一读的原因。可以说，这是尼基塔·谢泼德森（Nikita Sheppardson）、维姬·杰维斯（Vicky Jervis）博士和我本人的合作成果，它通过镜头或为自我认同为自闭症患者的人群提供了现实生活中的视角，展示了他们看待世界的方式、塑造他们经历的方式以及他们如何在心理健康领域成功地工作。里面有心理学家，有精神病学家，有处于职业生涯不同阶段的各种各样的人，这是一本引人入胜的
read. So I hope you find that really useful. If you read it already, I would love if you'd put a review on Amazon and Goodreads. If you would find future episodes on autism and being autistic or any element of kind of neuro diversity, please do let me know by dropping me a comment on YouTube and or connecting with me on social media where I am Dr. Marianne Trent everywhere. Inspiring psychologist podcasts with Dr. Mary Entrace Hi, my name is Beth and I'm a psychological wellbeing practitioner from Newcastle. I just wanted to say the biggest thank you to the contributors of the Clinical Psychologist Collective Book. I've enjoyed reading this so much and have loved having insight into the range of backgrounds and experiences people have prior to applying
读物。所以我希望你觉得这真的很有用。如果你已经读过了，我很希望你能在亚马逊和 Goodreads 上写一篇书评。如果您希望将来听到关于自闭症、身为自闭症患者或神经多样性任何元素的节目，请在 YouTube 上给我留言和/或在社交媒体上与我联系，我在所有地方都是 Dr. Marianne Trent。玛丽安·恩特雷斯博士的鼓舞人心的心理学家播客。嗨，我叫贝丝，我是来自纽卡斯尔的心理健康从业者。我只想对《临床心理学家集体书籍》的撰稿人们表示最衷心的感谢。我非常喜欢阅读这本书，并且很高兴能深入了解人们在申请之前所拥有的各种背景和经验
for the doctorate and it's been really interesting seeing the potential barriers to the application as well and how I can try and work around this. I really started to doubt myself and whether I was good enough to apply for the clinical psychology doctorate but this has really given me the confidence boost that I needed to give it a shot so the biggest thank you ever. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
对于博士学位，看到申请的潜在障碍以及我如何努力克服这些障碍也非常有趣。我真的开始怀疑自己，怀疑自己是否有资格申请临床心理学博士学位，但这确实给了我试一试所需的信心，因此我致以最最衷心的感谢。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。